normally I look at games a particular
player I go to the front desk of the
Chess Club ask for a letter of the
alphabet which I did today
and then I changed my mind the letter I
was given with Z and the best part could
think of was Z was all you already know
was Vadim's Vagan sev and then I was
like yeah nobody's heard of him but me
and maybe his mom maybe his mom you know
he's like wait what do you say him so no
I know his dad hasn't heard of him
so I decided let's look at some
technical positions from King and pawn
and rook and pawn endings I have eight
positions then we'll take about six
minutes on each one and then you'll you
can review later and like that now this
is one of my favorite positions for the
following reason I have a student that I
taught for six years who eventually just
recently got his last I am norm and I
started teaching when he was six and
when he was an expert I showed him this
position and I said white to play and
made in how many moves and he thought
for about 20 seconds and he gave the
right answer and I another student who
only had a lesson with once and I said
let's play this position out we played
it out for about five minutes and he
said I guess it's a draw that he was
over 2200 so I never taught him before
so that was okay of course this is not a
draw however because of all the
stalemate tricks white actually has to
sacrifice his pawn on h7 now for
somebody who plays a lot of one-minute
chests which is me you have to know how
to make quickly with the king and a
queen or king in a rook and other
situations too so not only do you have
to know how to win these you have to
know how to win them quickly at the
Grandmaster level we just resign okay
unless while certain players never
resigned but like me okay but I have a
good excuse I never lose so good reason
not to resign all right so make sure all
your opponent's are a thousand points
less that you'll never lose you there
while you lose occasionally okay so
obviously the
move is let's see who knows Bensimon
now even Bensimon knows h a queen okay
in black tanks now again if you have
five or six seconds on your clock i
recommend making the right move here if
you make the wrong move you will not
meet your opponent in five or six
seconds make the right move you will and
the right move is anyone and you want
you King up six right if you play King
aged six putting it in age which is
usually right then your opponent runs to
the middle and yeah you'll win maybe not
the kids in my camp but most of you at
home will win well some of you will okay
not if you will but if you probably King
of six now you're looking good okay and
that's saying something because I've
seen you in the morning and not looking
good
King GA and so on and now I give this
position to my beginning kids at class I
ask them what's the quickest way for
whites to mate and the answer is and
Simon
ah he wasn't expecting that Queen g3
right because you want the black king to
go towards you now for some reason 99%
of my students play Queen here made
nobody ever goes here so it's easier
because one square instead of three okay
and so as you have surmised the answer
to my question to a to Leah the the
international master was it's made in
seven so one not there two three four
five six and seven
and he said mate in seven because he'd
figured it out if you don't play the
move h8 Queen you won't win because
black wolf is king back and forth and if
White's king of her saunters to any of
these squares then it's going to be
stalemate that reminds you of a funny
story because I like stories I was in a
kid's tournament many many many years
ago I have a lot of stories from that we
probably just have a lecture I tell
stories from kids tournaments because
they're pretty funny telling this to
reminds me of like a hundred other
stories but this story was king and
queen versus King and somehow I
watching it and the kid with the Queen
still mated his opponent but he did it
on purpose he played the movement said
stalemate was really proud and I said do
you know what that means what they're
like no I said that means the game is a
draw and he says okay great okay he was
like still me I know it still need is
okay so he knew it was but he didn't
really realize that checkmate was better
he just thought I was tell me it's good
and I thought one more story because I
can't help it I I was in the kids to
rouse a director and kid raised his hand
and I said yeah and he said yeah I think
it's stalemate I looked at the board and
I kid you not his King wasn't checked by
five pieces so I said to his opponent do
you agree it still may they agree what I
care right and his answer was what
stalemate so that went back to the first
kid and I said you know what stalemate
is he goes yeah it's your turn to move
you have no legal move and you're not in
check I don't know what to say so I said
your king is in check by all of your
opponent's pieces and he said oh that's
right it's Chuck me and his opponent
said you're not in checkmate move here
and he's like I only moved there and
then I walked away there's a publish
pretty helpful you're not in checkmate
move your king over there that yeah yeah
oh that's right checkmate I confuse my
yeah I don't know well the King's been
checked by five pieces I tried to not
put my hand in there yeah um now I
wasn't involved in this kid's story
going off on a tangent a director friend
of mine told me he went to a board he he
was the kids and raised their hand
he just had to put his two cents in and
he said how come neither one of you has
a king and and there and one of the kids
answered no no no we traded those a long
time ago
it was a fair trade time so yeah and my
last story I promise I was in the kids
tournament in New York one kid had all
her pieces their kid a king and the King
start chasing the king like next to the
other King the kid would move away so
the illegal movie illegal and then when
black played King AAA I was really
looking forward to king a7 I wanted to
see what would happen and the kid would
just king back instead of King age 7 I
almost made him play king a7 just to see
what would happen okay so all right so
this lecture the games are slightly
higher quality slightly okay and I have
a million more stories like you haven't
fortunately all right now this is the
most important position in chess there
is no more important position this is
the only one that matters right right
yeah everybody agrees okay
black has three legal moves okay and as
meatloaf would say two out of three lose
or he'd say they're not bad you with
some crazy comment what's the answer
King g8 you must be prepared for King f6
or King age sex unfortunately if you
want to beep I've seen 1450 hundreds
lose these positions all the time all
the time and the reason the way you can
beat them well if you get them for less
than five minutes you're going to win
for sure the other way you're going to
beat them is when you have a position
like this like half the time they go
here because that's the opposition okay
but basically you always go back and
forth which is hard to remember okay so
if you can legally play King to g7 you
do if you can't legally play by King g8
I know that's hard to remember but but
okay this looks like the opposition but
okay and then okay white wins and this
looks very familiar because we just
looked at it yeah okay but King G it
obviously is a draw and the game ends in
steel mill though if I was white I would
move by King around and win eventually
against well all the kids in the chess
camp okay all of them yeah
yes against most of them yeah not all of
them because you know some of them
talented okay like markovia would draw
if he was still me okay so yeah you
basically the rule is for those of you
at home play King GA King g7 and take a
nap
okay then when you wake up your port has
a queen on the board alright so this is
a draw and this is a very important
position this position you can apply to
all positions where it's a king then
upon the new king anywhere on the board
you just move your king back and forth
so King f8 losing I guess that should be
read King h8 losing King g8
ding-ding-ding and somehow Julian got it
very impressive okay somehow okay now
this is different this I usually try to
trick the kids because you know tricks
are for kids and I ask them is this a
win or a draw and some say win and some
say draw and they're both wrong I like
that okay the correct answer is Julian
whose turn is it that's the correct
answer
it's White's turn the position is a draw
it's blacks turn black loses and if it's
your turn and you lose
that's called no now if it's your turn
and all of your moves lose you are in
right and I was in camp today and I
showed his Lucas long position and the
kids like oh I know what that's called
and he I don't know what he said but it
had his D in it
that's all I don't had a Z it was like
Zhang Wang Wang Chung you know missions
now you didn't say that
Zook retort okay ZZ Top he said
everything but zoogs one yeah so this is
called the opposition and when it when I
say that word opposition that means he
was ever eternities is in trouble
so it's White's terms that's what the
computer does and black just follows
white whatever white does black does the
same thing eventually white gets tired
of that and starts moving the pawn and
we've already seen this position but you
forgot it was like three minutes ago
okay and okay King GA king
kingi it's hard to remember King g7 King
g8 that's tough to do but it's a draw
and eventually we have a stalemate which
is a draw game not in checkers but in
chess okay and and so forth so if we go
back to the beginning
okay Emerson Lake & Palmer style that
right that's right yeah in the beginning
man they don't know music in this room
terrible
we're Saudi endeavour I said every time
it was just the audience it's not me
all right so let's pretend it's black
smooth by cheating a little okay yay now
it's black smooth good so this is a
starting position it was black to move
black would have to give way white wants
to move his king forward which is
illegal although in the chess camp it's
common and now black was let's say this
way and we move the other way and Vicey
Versy if we go here than here and we
escort our pawn home and if you go back
we go forward and once the white king
gets to one of these squares then these
will be the next four moves and
hopefully commit with the Queen
hopefully I mean you can't
but hopefully okay so again this is
lubes wang if it's your turn to move
you're in trouble
especially if you're white okay all
right now we go a little harder Oh No
now one thing most people know most
people even people don't play chess if
your pawns are connected okay well you
know they know like some off you guys
nothing now you agree right yeah she's
like I don't know all right so if you're
connected then your pawns protect each
other so if like this pawn is here but I
can't do anything here the pawns also
protect each other so even without a
king white is okay so why it's going to
move his King towards his pawns and
eventually win if black wants to capture
the pawns it can't be done if you attack
even upon I guess I can't do that if I
take either pawn the other pawn moves
you can't capture because this pawn is
too fast and we make a queen and if we
do it the other way
King aged five
obviously f5 it's the same thing king
takes pawn and and we can't now black
doesn't have to do that black could do
nothing movies came back and forth but
eventually White's going to move his
King and win and if there if black tries
to after this go back around okay
now if white moves either pawn he's
going to lose the pawn but he can move
his king and now I'll move it to the
worst square and now white wins by
playing out five and again we're ready
for either move we move this here so
these separated pawns you can't capture
them both and if you capture one the
other one's going to Queen so even if
the King is really far away that's the
furthest away I think of was a one it's
still winning so it is a 1 right Arjun
is a one-year favorite you can order a
steak ok we're going to do rook and pawn
now I've set up three different
positions with the same idea in fact
there was a game in Charlotte in the
Charlotte not the Charlotte and the
Carolina juniors Invitational which had
this theme the theme is White's trying
to Queen his pawn and now he's stuck he
can't take his own rock they wouldn't do
anyway and blacks rook is behind the
pawn so if white moves his rook he loses
his pawn it's a draw okay now if white
starts moving his King to escort his
pawn sounds good right okay then as soon
as he gets there Oh before we can check
forever there's nowhere to hide we can't
you know fit in between or maybe I can
you know now white wins okay so King a
seven and a half X clam okay we can't do
that so we check forever and this is
like the boring world of niels bohr
can't do nothing okay and if it was like
niels bohr probably commit suicide at
eighteen right right according to Julian
anyway
Julian's like wait a minute yeah okay
and if we come down to attack the rook
then we don't care if you come up to get
the rook then we don't care and this is
a draw because you just check forever
but White has another way to try to win
White has another past pawn and I'm
trying to show as Jonathan shrimps would
say this pawn is useless
and I hope Peter and Kelly think that's
funny okay because only they can get
that joke I may be a view alright so the
plot HQ is useless because if we start
moving that pawn okay now black can
blunder if he wants who wants to blunder
put your hand down at home okay no you
can leave your hand up then we can take
this pawn no okay if I was at chess camp
today I would win this 11 out of 10 but
you yeah yeah I really win yeah I'd what
yeah the guy would resign twice yeah
okay
so King takes pawn is a blunder now
White's winning who can find the winning
move Arjen Rick H a stalemate no just
kidding
and then we Queen and Arjen knows how to
mate with a rug right that's really hard
isn't it gimme with two bishops three
bishops on the same color okay that's
better
you think attention okay so what black
has to do is nothing
game and as anybody who's met me will
tell you I'm the master of nothing okay
so now black just goes rook here look
here look here for ever and white has no
plan now the same can be said for the
pawn on g2 or if it's on g3 yeah that's
how g3 sorry okay
and this is the exact same except
eventually white can put black and Shaq
Black has three legal moves again this
is a meatloaf type position I don't like
it why don't I like it I'm a vegetarian
okay and meanwhile would say two out of
three ain't bad so we got three moves
one of them draws and two of them
who can find the drawing move other than
Julian how does black draw Black has one
good move if only our jinwu is your hand
up I can't tell
are you just resting you were like ready
to arm wrestle Oh what's going on Joe
look at him he's got his arm in yeah
he's ready yeah are you offering me to
kick can to call on you okay you King g7
right after King g7 again Black has this
plan of doing nothing okay now we can
blunder if we want and if your plank
knee I recommend it you can play King
takes pawn which loses two and Simon rip
g8 Shaq and then we Queen or you can
play King age six and obviously rook H a
check and Queen okay so you can't win
with the H pawn or the G pawn in this
particular setting it's a draw okay
however the last setting of this
particular example is this one and we
have an F pawn now why is this important
thanks for asking because sometimes
you'll have a position where you have
free pawns against two or two pawns
against two or two pawns against one on
the Kings side and you can sacrifice a
pawn to get a past F pawn a past G pawn
or a past age pawn or even just get a
passed pawn for no reason and the G and
H pawns don't win the F pawn does win
and actually in the game I was referring
to earlier in the Carolina Junior
Championship why did get the past F pawn
and he did win and the way we win is we
push our pawn until black takes it if
black doesn't take it that's also good
we'll make a queen so white plays f4 and
f5 and we can check them but okay I can
run towards your rock I'm not that
concerned okay
eventually the checks run out okay and
now we play f6 check this position is
winning because of a very nice trick
obviously if the King goes to the 3rd
we've already seen several times in this
lecture the rook will check the king and
then the pawn will Queen if King h7 f7
is looking good then we're going to play
f8 so the key to all of chess is king f7
and if we have a G pawn or an H pawn
this is a draw because the pawns on f6
now white is winning what is the winning
move it's always the same people Joe
okay Jade right okay and you can't play
rook a chain when blacks King is on g7
or h7 because that would be bad now
after we take the pawn we play rook
check then we win the rook over here now
what is a new a sir and control in yeah
yes that's too hard to remember okay now
one thing I want to tell you about this
is if you have this position without
upon a lot of times people who don't
defend well with black will blunder and
lose this is a draw as we discussed
earlier but black can lose if he wants
okay the way to draw is to just play
King h7 King g7 that's a draw but maybe
some of you are like hey I'm going to go
over and win that pawn okay and those
lose all lose so if you play king f7
it's the same as the last puzzle rook
here Rick takes pawn and rook check wins
so it's actually funny sometimes we see
positions where black is racing away
from the pawn amazing although not too
amazing okay so we have a position like
this let's put the King here and let's
put the rook here let's put the King
here put the pawn a sixth ring to make
it tough okay so I make sure I'm gonna
put it on f5 because that's a good
puzzle that's better
well that's pretty good okay so in this
position if black runs towards the pawn
he's going to lose because for example
King here here and there's no drawing
move the drawing moves our King b7 King
c7 King g7 and King age 7 so unless you
cheat you can't make one of those moves
also King be six draws but I missed it
and King C six draws yeah sorry
indeed although why's your king on a6
it was on b5 or b6o you went there cuz
now if your King was on c5 you would
play Kings you play King b6 if your King
was on yeah you have your drawing move
Cho okay so here even though you're
running towards the pawn you don't have
to what you can here if you want to draw
you go back to g7 and h7 now if white
wants to win White has to try to win
this way move his king if he's greedy it
tries to Queen right away black has two
drawing moves okay and now we can't play
rook check because the King will take
and we can't go around because there's
nowhere to go and this is the easy draw
so running towards the pawn is often
worse than running away from the pawn
because you're trying to stop this Rick
h8 trick and yeah obviously you've heard
many times
rooks go behind passed pawns Black has
drawing chances and is often drawing
because his rook is behind the pass pawn
white wishes his other way around which
is the next position okay so again your
book wants to go behind the pass pawn
then when you push the pass pawn your
rook has more squares and your
opponent's trick has fewer squares in
this position white rook can't move at
all if it does you just lose your pawn
so if the rooks are reversed and white
had a passed pawn it would be a very
easy win for example let's put a black
rook here and a white rook here and give
white this stupid pawn
okay now this is no problem okay white
wins easily this route can't move white
has this plan and a flax like no you're
not going to do that I'm going to stop
you well I got another pine okay so
since the pawns are on the outside
blacks king can go in both directions
white wins easily if the rooks are
reversed then black draws easily here
blacks rook can't move and the other
examples White's truck can't move and
Gregory cut Donovan I have had many
intellectual discussions very
intellectual right Julian okay and in
some of them we talk about chess camps
and our kids are like I have double
ponds they start crying they don't care
that their pieces can't move okay
they're like oh no my puns isolated and
I'm like you have meat in one what do
you care so pawn structures okay
but piece activities more important here
whites rook is active blacks for a can't
move in the original examples it was the
other way around
Julian with a crazy comment refuting
what I said so what Julian's asking is
let's do the original position except
instead of the point on a seven pawns on
a six so is this good or no now White's
going to try to win by hiding his king
then eventually we can Queen the pawn
and if blacks like no you can't move
your king then this pawn is pretty
strong so if black baby sits the pawn
the question is can he win this pawn
while whites doing this okay yes you
were thinking Arby's yeah
you mean intentionally go up your H pawn
or put it on H six then King H seven and
not give it away
hmmm then there's still matrix I can't
figure out I can't figure them out
though exactly so let's do what you said
let's give you everything you want you
got that you're happy okay
by the way when you play h6 I can take
it so let's put it on h5 all right now I
go here so I'm going to take it right
yeah and also your Kings cut off that's
terrible
okay so we do something like this yeah
now you're going to want to get what's
that guy's name
then Qura yeah you're going to want the
VIN current position and even though
super GM's messed that up
so you're going to want to do something
like you're defending from the side okay
and then if the King starts doing what
you want to do I check from the side so
you can't do it and when you go here
then I go back so yeah you're going to
want to draw that way and that was shown
recently when I say recently it was 2011
in Moscow wasn't your recent repo
Miyaichi Nakamura so if you look at me
palm Miyaichi Nakamura Tom Memorial 2011
I think he used the Vaughn current
method to draw happens like once a year
at the Super GM level and half the time
they mess it up yeah there was it a non
game was who I mean with whom I'm sorry
and they messed it up for like one move
might have been with Carlsen by the way
in the first match when I was discussing
you know nan Carlsen I said they're both
of the world's worst rook and pawn
endgame players both of them like take
turns blundering recombine endings and
then anon loss to Drama Camp on endings
he showed me okay and then when Carlson
was playing wang hao
two years ago they got to add Ron Ricky
Ponting wearisome was worse that he lost
yeah yeah the worst both of them now he
wasn't trying to win what spawned out
for nothing
however there's the famous you know Karl
single upon tomorrow everyone four
versus four how many pata Mario is the
worst okay
so the answer is it depends now here's
the problem with these end games you
might think I have table bases and rub
your fans together
okay the table bases say every move
draws and there's no method they just
know what to draw so you can't really
learn how to do it because they're like
every move drawn then you're like I want
to know a method so any position I can
figure it out and they don't really help
you some books help you but the books
were written in the 40s 50s and 60s then
they're wrong that's not helping you
either so you can't learn just give up
play golf okay
you know you got a chance now okay so
when the pawns on the seventh no good on
the six you have a chance now I have a
rule and you know my rule is Alric and
bindings are winning and that's for
practical reasons okay if you see a real
component in a tournament somebody's
going to win even it's a super GM level
guys like anandhan Carlsen make their
living losing drawn rook and pawn
endings okay that keeps them like a
human level you know not super computer
and they do it all the time for example
you're in pick at your favorite Dutch
Grand Master who retired 20 years ago he
because Favre Rick and four versus Rick
and three on the same side Ivica sprog
couldn't draw Carlsen Kasparov Anand
always losing drumroll coupon endings
terrible I never do that because I
always start out losing so I don't have
a drummer component yeah alright last
but not least of the least this is what
we were talking about if I remember
correctly and I don't very similar
ending happened and Jochen is that you
pronounce it I pronounce it the Russian
we put out to the American Way thanks
again Alexander are Jochen vs. kappa
blanka in there match what year
you neither one was alive for a long
time at that point anybody that was
worse than his answer he's just making
you feel good are by giving you a worse
answer anybody you see what I put up
with here yet
19:27 you guys are the worst
i an't and that ending the pawn the rook
was behind the pass pawn this works in
frying is this good for white or black
white white rook is behind the pass pawn
if black rook moves the pawn keeps going
the winning method is simple if we can
somehow attack this rook that we can
Queen our pawn if black says no you
can't attack my rook I'm going to put my
king there then we can walk over here
and take these pawns the problem is even
if we give black a thousand moves in a
row and let him play King here King here
King here and let him take the pawn that
he's still losing okay we can trade and
then this Kings terrible we're ready to
go
so black could never take that pawn and
black could never move his rook anywhere
what grandmasters usually try to do it
doesn't work they try to do it is they
try to put their King on a seven and
then their look is free that loses two
but it's tougher so white does nothing
because White's playing silly and then
black does this and says okay now I can
try to draw and you can't draw but you
can try
and black usually can't achieve that
because White's actually making moves so
this is a pretty easy win because this
rook is terrible there's no activity and
if you move the rook White's going to
just Queen and white either was this
King here if black stops him white moves
his King here so an easy win and what we
often see in these end games is we get a
position where
you're like well could you move your
king somewhere so I could decide which
way to go and blacks like No so then
what do we play argent how do we lose it
lose a tempo with white it's not raining
you know with a crazy answer that's
right yeah we play too and we say I dare
you to move your king I double dare you
speak English in what that's what we say
now black can obviously move pawns but
pawn moves run out why can do the same
and if black goes this way we attack the
rock the flat goes this way we take all
the pawns and we get four Queens
although in chess camp yesterday two
different kids said you can't have more
than three Queens this is three I don't
know they got three from but they were
different kids so somebody taught them
that I guess you can't have four Queen
lave three so you got eight Queens what
a teacher all right
your indolence yeah terrible okay so to
recap in the endgame ah scared okay
let's get in the endgame you want to
Queen if you don't Queen you won't win
you might and you need to stop your
opponent from queening having passed
pawns is important having an active King
is important having an active rook is
important and when your rook is behind
your past pon everytime you move your
pawn forward your opponent's rook has
less squares you want your look behind
the pawn not on the side for example if
we cheat a little bit cheating is good
wait how did I do that I can just keep
moving I know I know it's taking it back
okay so in this position if you had the
white pieces you could play rip b5
terrible we're k1 also terrible because
Rick p6 check wins okay but the idea is
in this position if you could play rip
b5 or rook a1 you would play rook a1 the
reason
is if your work is on the side which is
probably also winning now blacks work
can actually move and in fact he can try
to get behind the pawn for example here
I'm behind the pawn I'm losing a mind
the pun so that was impressive okay
and so your opponent's for a can can
move when you go here because then we
start queening okay then that doesn't
look good for black then we go here when
you're a grandmaster you can do that in
one move otherwise it takes you four
okay yeah
King b7 also when you're reading it's
really how you can resign for your
opponent right Julian he's like yeah I
and one more story before class
dismissed
I was playing Florin Falcon the I am
from Chicago and every move I thought he
would resign but he didn't resign and he
went to make a move and I thought he was
putting his hand out to resign so I put
my hand out and he and there was obvious
he was making a movie he looked at me he
went and he resigned so even in slow
tournament chess I make my opponent
resign so remember if you're losing put
your hand out they might not on do that